Щойно 32-річний ветеран Анатолій уперше в житті
осідлав коня: без однієї ноги і без допомоги милиць.
Після втрати кінцівки у боях за звільнення Роботиного на Запоріжжі,
чоловік боявся повертатися до цивільного життя.
Прийшовши на перше тренування їзди верхи,
він зміг побороти свій страх великих тварин - допоміг йому кінь Комбат.
Ну, Комбат! Як сказати… Він спокійний, це найголовніше.
До нього підійти можна, погладити. Приємно дуже. Трохи боявся.
Я радий, що сходив, звісно, не хотів йти. Але потім передумав.
Я чути-чув, але ніколи не цікавився цим.
Усі ветерани, які сьогодні прийшли на заняття, раніше не знали про те,
що з бойовими травмами можуть їздити верхи.
Тим паче, що це може перерости у професійний адаптивний спорт.
Адже після тривалої підготовки на іподромі ветерани мають шанс
потрапити на змагання. Для Олега, який пережив тяжке поранення руки
під Кремінною на Луганщині, перша спроба зайнятися спортом
стала мотивацією швидше реабілітуватися.
Ти стараєшся чимось довести, що ти повноцінний.
Вважають, що в тебе щось не працює, як в інших.
Але ти змушуєш себе, працюєш, бачиш,
коли результати позитивні, воно мотивує.
Саме відчуття мотивації жити далі у своїх підопічних намагається
розвинути Андрій Кучер, який є ментором групи ветеранів
під час тренування з конями. Він сам пройшов шлях відновлення
після поранення під Мар'їнкою торік.
Я розумів, що діється хаос. Якби мені побратими не підказали, я б і не знав.
Я б не знав, як отримати виплати, належне лікування,
і не би отримав реабілітації. Тобто я випав би із системи.
Система мене не бачить. Я - нуль. Я хочу, щоб статус ветерана
нарешті став цінністю в цій державі. Я хочу, щоб ми як братерство
ветеранів росли, зростали і допомагали один одному.
Саме це братерство рік тому підтримало Андрія.
Із кількома побратимами він почав активно займатися
легкою атлетикою. А вже цієї весни представлялв Україну
на Іграх Нескорених у Румунії, взявши участь у забігу на 21 кілометр.
Після власних успіхів ветеран почав спонукати до адаптивного спорту
інших ветеранів. Завів мотиваційний блог у соцмережах
і став спортивним амбасадором, пройшовши тренерський курс
від фонду "Повернись живим". Нині Андрій - один із професійних
менторів для ветеранів з усієї країни.
Відібрали 20 ветеранів з різних областей України для того,
щоб ми пройшли навчання і потім змогли свої знання
реалізовувати в себе в громаді. У нас були теоретичні заняття,
у нас були практичні заняття. Тобто ми багато приділяли уваги
саме тренерству, саме адаптивним видам спорту: і легка атлетика,
і хендбайк, і баскетбол на візках, і волейбол сидячи.
Саме спорт нас повертає в життя!
Критеріями відбору амбасадорів були досвід ветерана у реабілітації
та адаптивному спорті і можливість самостійно згуртувати ветеранів
навколо себе, як це нині робить Андрій у Києві.
Мета була створити з них маленьку спільноту, щоб вони прожили
досвід позитивного спілкування з іншими ветеранами,
не навколо чарки, а навколо спільної діяльності, яка заряджає.
По всій Україні амбасадори допомагають одне одному
організовувати турніри і шукати необхідне спорядження
для своїх підопічних. Так вдалося влаштувати місцеве змагання
зі стрільби з лука для ветеранів на Львівщині.
Це була мрія двох колишніх бійців, а нині - чемпіонів Ігор Нескорених
у цьому виді адаптивного спорту - Павла Лучківа та Сергія Шимчака.
Я відчував таку гостру несправедливість:
чому ветерани нікому не потрібні? Всі навкруги заявляють про те,
що реабілітація, ветерани, всі дуже сильно, гарно допомагають...
Але коли вимикаються камери, мікрофони, воно чомусь зникає.
Я знаю, який я шлях пройшов. І я би не хотів, щоб інші хлопці,
які теж горять бажанням займатися, щоб вони ставали на ті самі граблі.
Бо я бачу, що багато хлопців залишають цей спорт,
якраз через те, що їм тяжко придбати матеріальну частину,
бо вона не така вже й дешева. І найголовніше -
немає, де тренуватися.
Спільними зусиллями Павлу і Сергію кілька тижнів тому вдалося
домовитися з місцевою владою Львова про виділення
цього приміщення для занять з ветеранами.
Але для тренування хоча б десятьох охочих одночасно поки не вистачає
луків і мішеней. Тому новачків набирають малими групами.
Серед них Олег.
Дізнався, що буде змагання в Штатах проходити, і відбір буде в грудні.
Хочеться підготуватися. Я не знаю, чи пройду той відбір.
По-різному буває, трошечки синці набиваю!
Отримав травму і лягати: "Все, вже не можу нічого робити"? Та ну!
Тут головне - не треба нав'язувати нічого, треба зацікавити.
Просто якщо ви зацікавите ветерана, будь-якого, якщо ви його зацікавите,
це є вже 50% перемоги.
Будучи в паралімпійській збірній, скільки я поїздив на чемпіонати світу,
Кубки Європи, я бачив, що люди незрячі стріляють,
люди, які не мають рук, стріляють краще, ніж здорові.
Мотивація у ветеранської спільноти є.
Однак створення окремої спортивної федерації - наразі лише мрія,
кажуть у фонді "Повернись живим". Адже фінансів поки не вистачає
навіть на те, щоб повністю забезпечити проєкти амбасадорів.
Воно росте знизу, і те, що знизу - має потужний фундамент.
Потім можна оформляти вже у законодавчі ініціативи,
тому що для мене так виглядає демократія.
Це тоді, коли нас стане так багато, вже настільки дієвих,
що на наші змагання будуть приїжджати тисячі людей,
різні, з різних регіонів ветеранів, і паралельно тоді можна робити
ветеранський спорт, федерацію ветеранського спорту.
Ветеран Андрій Кучер сподівається знайти фінансування
для приміщення і тренувань свої підопічних за кордоном.
Ми увійшли в топ-100 організацій Києва, маючи пів року
за плечима роботи. Але це не ціль, це спосіб привернути увагу!
І тоді в нас підтягнуться і результати. І тоді наші спортсмени будуть
вигравати. А ви ж знаєте, нам багато не треба, українці достатньо завзяті!
Наразі заняття з їзди верхи Андрій організовує у співпраці
з волонтерами та реабілітаційними центрами.
У планах - не сходити зі спортивного шляху та взяти "золото"
на наступних Іграх Нескорених - вже у команді зі своїми підопічними.